Dr. Gears was having another boring day at
the SCP Foundation - and that was exactly
how he liked it.
He’d treated himself to a cup of decaf black
coffee - no cream, no sugar - a single plain
donut, and an apple.
The breakfast of champions, to him at least.
His duties today were ones he’d overseen
so many times before: Watching his ever-rotating
legion of subordinates shove various items
into SCP-914, the Clockworks, just to see
what on earth would happen.
This machine had the ability to transmute
matter in a variety of fashions, depending
on the input selection, whether Rough, Course,
One To One, Fine, or even Very Fine.
They’d tested everything - from Dr. Gears’
watch to a chimp, which, as we all know, resulted
in the beloved hyper-intelligent chimp scientist,
Dr. Bobo.
There were, in fact, such extensive testing
records for SCP-914 that Dr. Gears had started
taking an uncharacteristic hands-off approach
to testing.
As long as the researchers working under him
were reasonably sure that the results of their
testing wouldn’t result in a containment
breach, a fundamental alteration of consensus
reality, or some massive loss of life, they
could just go ahead with whatever dumb little
experiment their heart desired.
This, however, would turn out to be a way
longer leash than Dr. Gears ever should have
given to the kinds of weirdos who work at
the SCP Foundation.
There had been certain, let’s say, incidents
in the past that have proved members of the
SCP Foundation aren’t above using anomalies
inappropriately for their own personal enjoyment.
There was, of course, the incident with SCP-662,
the Butler’s Hand Bell, and the supernatural
Butler it summons, Mr. Deeds.
During the early stages of testing, Dr. Mirth,
under the guise of experimentation, made Mr.
Deeds make him tea, wash his car, cut his
hair, and even do his laundry.
Dr. Mirth was given a stern talking to by
the O5 Council for this abuse of power.
Good job, O5 Council.
It’s not like you ever use anomalies for
your own benefit.
Uhhh...
Let’s move on, nothing to see here, folks.
Speaking of people working for the Foundation
using anomalies inappropriately, who could
forget the extremely uncomfortable incident
involving SCP-137, A Real Toy.
This anomaly has the ability to become a real-life
version of any toy brought into its vicinity,
from the Masters of the Universe to Barbie
in her Dream House.
But one researcher was hiding a horrifying
secret: He was...
A Brony.
And that’s why he sneaked a Twilight Sparkle
toy into the testing chamber, so he could
have a conversation with his favorite My Little
Pony Character, which all in attendance agreed
just had incredibly rancid vibes through and
through.
And that brings us back to today: Dr. Gears
deciding to let his subordinate researchers
throw pretty much anything into the Clockworks
as long as it was unlikely to cause physical
harm.
And leaving this metaphorical door open allowed
people like Dr. Segal to step through.
You see, while Dr. Segal was considered by
most to be an incredibly diligent and hard-working
junior researcher, he did have one vice in
his downtime: He was a card-carrying Furry.
And we’re not just talking about a guy who
watched Disney’s Zootopia a few too many
times, he had his own fursona - a Wolf, if
you were curious - he attended cons for fellow
furries semi-frequently and even had his own
expensive, custom, high-end fur suit.
As such, there was one SCP he found particularly
interesting: SCP-1471, also known as MalO
ver1.O.O, an anomalous mobile app with some
extremely strange properties.
If you access it on an App Store of your choice,
you’ll encounter an image of a strange,
skull-headed canine creature, with the following
iconic description:
MalO
ver1.O.O
FREE!
Reviews (O)
Description:
Never settle for those awkward feelings of
being alone ever again.
MalO is an exciting and interactive experience
that will keep you engaged and intrigued.
The anxiety of social situations can be nerve-racking,
but after just a few hours of MalO you will
soon forget all about those painful emotions
of disappointment.
Be part of the new craze that is quickly becoming
the next social substitute.
Remember, the more you participate, the more
MalO will engage you.
Your experience is completely up to you.
Absolutely NO ADS.
Enjoy!
Dr. Segal was certainly eager to forget all
his painful emotions of disappointment and
embrace the new social substitute.
But he’d read all the documents and seen
all the pictures on the file: Those who download
the MalO app will be texted a series of photos,
becoming closer to home over time, both literally
and figuratively, which show the strange creature
known as MalO getting closer and closer.
For some, this would be a complete nightmare.
For those inclined in the direction of Dr.
Segal, it would be a dream come true.
There was only one issue: They were just pictures.
But Dr. Segal didn’t get a job at the SCP
Foundation by having a lack of intelligence.
He’d very quickly figured out a potential
solution to the digital barrier between him
and his canid crush: He’d buy a burner phone,
download the MalO app onto it, and put the
resulting infected device directly into the
Clockworks.
It was one of the best ideas he’d ever had,
in his own humble opinion.
But of course, it would all be about selecting
the right setting.
On Rough, the most likely result would be
the phone itself just being transformed into
a pile of broken glass, metal, and a variety
of conflict minerals reduced to dust.
On Coarse, the result would likely be the
metal chassis of the phone, the front glass
panel, and a neatly arranged interior gutted
from within.
On 1:1, considering he’d bought a slightly
older, cheaper model of Samsung Smart Phone,
he’d probably just get the MalO app on an
iPhone.
And on Fine, perhaps the best he could hope
for was getting MalO Ver 2.O.O, which would
maybe have some minor improvement like the
pictures appearing twice as fast as they would
with the normal app experience.
Dr. Segal knew that the only option that could
potentially bring MalO into the real world
was the highly unpredictable Very Fine option,
which would either produce the desired result
or cause something utterly horrifying to happen.
But at the end of the day, Dr. Segal thought
to himself, isn’t anything worth having
also worth incurring a little risk?
Who dares, wins, after all, right?
He downloaded the fateful app and made his
way into the testing area for SCP-914.
He’d booked the slot, so it was all official,
but he still felt his heart racing as he put
the infected phone into the Input chamber.
He set the control panel to Very Fine, exactly
as planned, and activated the machine.
Cogs twisted and churned, engines rumbled
and sputtered, pipes wriggled and hissed.
It was clear that something was going on here.
When the process was complete and the Output
chamber opened with a billowing carpet of
steam, Dr. Segal could barely contain his
excitement.
He hoped that MalO would come strolling out
of the smoke like Darth Vader in Star Wars:
A New Hope, so you can only imagine his extreme
disappointment when the chamber was completely
empty.
It didn’t make sense.
He’d thought everything through.
How could the result possibly be so anti-climatic?
This had gone from one of the most exciting
days of his life to the most depressing.
Dr. Segal sighed and decided to call it quits,
heading out of the test chamber, having no
idea what he’d just unleashed onto the Foundation.
Across the site, Dr. Alto Clef, one of the
Foundation’s more infamous researchers,
was polishing his favorite shotgun in his
office.
He was whistling a cheerful tune to himself,
just loving life, when he heard some strange
rustling by the door.
He turned around on his swivel chair, just
to make sure it wasn’t Dr. Bright putting
another bucket of battery acid on top of his
door as a “fun, harmless prank.”
Instead, he was shocked to see MalO - an actual,
physical MalO - standing in his doorway, grinning.
For a moment, Clef was too shocked to even
react.
This didn’t make any kind of sense.
But when MalO gave him a cheeky wink, he immediately
loaded his shotgun and fired, blowing away
a chunk of his own doorway.
But sadly for him, by that time, MalO had
already darted away, intent on causing mischief
elsewhere, its favorite pastime.
Dr. Clef was still wondering whether that
rascal Dr. Bright was somehow behind this
fiasco...
But he was not, because he was actually about
to become MalO’s next victim in its ruthless
reign of mild to moderate inconvenience.
Dr. Bright was swanning around the break room
with his favorite morning snack: A coffee
with extra cream and a danish from his favorite
bakery in town.
He was looking forward to enjoying these two
simple pleasures in his otherwise incredibly
stressful life, but little did the poor doctor
know, tragedy was about to strike, and nothing
would ever be the same.
Just as the immortal doctor was about to disembark
from the room, MalO appeared right in front
of him, giving him the mild shock of his life.
It was such a surprising occurrence, in fact,
that he momentarily lost his grip on his coffee
mug and his danish, causing both to tumble
to the ground.
The mug shattered and the danish splattered.
By the time Dr. Bright looked up, MalO was
already gone, just like his breakfast snack.
Dr. Bright fell to his knees and screamed
“WHHYYYY?”
up to an indifferent break room ceiling.
But MalO was just getting started.
Dr. Kain Pathos Crow was on the way from his
kennel - ahem, we mean, his private quarters
- to the soul extractor when MalO suddenly
manifested in front of him.
This resulted in a brief barking match between
the two for dominance over that particular
hallway, which ended in MalO demanifesting
to bother someone else, which technically
made Dr. Crow the winner.
Though Crow himself resented ever being forced
to act like a mere mutt...
How, he began to wonder, had MalO escaped
its app and begun to harass the real world?
This would warrant further investigation.
MalO continued its rampage of irritation across
the site, intending to leave no stone of frustration
unturned.
And it wasn’t just the Foundation staff
it intended to freak out; it was just as eager
to go and bother its fellow anomalies now
it had access to meatspace.
Yes, that is a real term, we’re not just
being weird and gross, we promise.
Over in the cell of SCP-173, the Sculpture,
three members of D-Class personnel were cleaning
up the homicidal creature’s blood and poop.
They were engaged in the standard procedure.
One of them mopped, while the other two kept
a close eye on SCP-173 to keep it frozen in
place.
That’s when MalO popped into the cell behind
them for a split second before disappearing,
scaring the living hell out of all three of
them.
Though the fright was, of course, secondary
to the fact that the second they looked away,
SCP-173 snapped all three of their necks.
Oops.
May have gone a little too far on that one,
eh, MalO?
But this newly embodied burdensome beast was
just getting started, friends.
No anomaly was safe from its new antics.
Next, it appeared in front of SCP-682’s
acid tank, and pulled rude faces at the hateful
creature from the other side of the glass.
This only served to sour the creature’s
already utterly horrific mood.
It thrashed around in the chamber, attempting
to get out and perform an act of great violence,
but by that time MalO was already long gone,
and SCP-682 was left grumbling in immense
frustration.
SCP-049, the Plague Doctor, was having another
very boring day.
He’d been denied his animal cadaver test
subjects for several days as a disciplinary
measure after the latest incident, and as
such, he was finding other ways to pass the
time.
Today, he was meticulously removing each piece
of medical equipment, polishing them, and
putting them in a neat line on the desk of
his containment chamber.
Scalpels, forceps, speculums, bone saws.
All wonderful, shiny, and pristine.
The Plague Doctor found it to be an incredibly
calming activity.
So of course, MalO couldn’t just let him
be.
The cantankerous canine - driven mad by the
power of suddenly being able to interact with
the world physically - manifested in the middle
of the containment chamber and used its tail
to knock all of the meticulously-arranged
medical equipment onto the ground with a thunderous
clatter.
The Plague Doctor, devastated, lifted both
hands to his beak and yelled “Sacre Bleu!”
in horror.
In that same instant, MalO once again disappeared,
leaving the tragic doctor to start from scratch.
It was a serious setback on an otherwise lovely
day.
Curse you, strange dog creature, he thought
to himself while bending over to pick up the
pieces, curse you and your entire bloodline.
A group of hardcore Mobile Task Force members
was engaging in the comically manly activity
of playing poker while smoking in the barracks
- and before you judge them for that, remember
that if your job was as stressful as being
a member of a Mobile Task Force operative,
you’d probably smoke too.
But their job was about to get a little more
stressful when MalO suddenly materialized
and gave the poker table a sharp kick, sending
the towers of poker chips and deck of cards
all over the place, before disappearing without
a trace yet again.
It completely ruined their game.
One of the more junior members asked, “Should
we have done something about that?”
A more senior operative shook his head and
said, “We’ll do something when we get
the official call from the top.
Until then, let’s reshuffle the deck…”
In the Site-19 cafeteria, Dr. Agatha Rights
was preparing to eat a delicious salad that
she’d been waiting all day to enjoy.
As we’ve often established, working at the
SCP Foundation can be an immensely stressful
job, so you need to take the small joys where
you can get them, for Dr. Rights, this delicious
premium salad she bought from Harris Teeter
earlier in the day was indeed a joy.
She even got a fancy vinaigrette dressing
for the occasion.
Before she took the first bite, she noticed
SCP-073, Cain, approaching.
Dr. Rights smiled and gave him a polite nod.
Cain waved an arm to wave.
That, our dear viewers, is when tragedy struck.
MalO suddenly manifested in front of Cain,
propping out one of its canid legs right in
front of where the hapless anomaly was walking.
By the time Cain began to trip and fall over,
MalO had already vanished.
But it was too late.
Cain kept falling forward until one of his
metal hands landed right into the bowl that
contained Dr. Rights’ salad.
Due to his anomalous abilities, the salad
immediately withered away into nasty, dead
nothingness.
Dr. Rights began to cry, as Cain, who felt
profoundly guilty, tried his best to apologize.
Truly nobody in Site-19 was safe.
MalO popped up behind Iris and ruined all
of her photos.
MalO popped up behind the Immortal Hitler
Clone in his cell, and gave him a good kick
in the rear.
MalO even popped up behind SCP-343, also known
as God, who smugly replied, “I knew you
were going to do that, my son.”
Needless to say, it had been one hell of a
day.
Dr. Segal, completely ignorant to the chaos
his actions had caused around the site, had
cried in the bathroom for forty minutes out
of sheer disappointment.
He’d barely been able to focus on the rest
of his duties for the day, on account of being
severely bummed out.
This was a day he’d been looking forward
to for so long, and it’d all been for nothing.
That evening, he was driving home on the highway,
listening to sad songs on the radio, thinking
about the fact he’d probably just crack
open a beer and get some sleep when he got
home.
He sighed again and looked up to adjust his
rearview mirror, when he saw a skeletal face
with huge, white eyes staring at him in the
reflection.
A quick, almost reflexive turn revealed that
a huge, black figure with a canine skull for
a face was indeed just sitting in his back
seat, watching him.
It was so shocking that he immediately veered
off the road and crashed his car into the
concrete divider in the middle of the road,
breaking his nose and collarbone in the process.
Really a perfect cherry on top for this kind
of day.
Dr. Segal was sitting in the hospital not
long after that, with a cast around his upper
body.
This was also where he received a bouquet
of flowers from Dr. Gears, with an attached
note saying he was put on three-month disciplinary
leave for the irresponsible use of SCP-914.
Dr. Segal looked up and saw that MalO was
peering around the corner at him with its
dead, white eyes, its fang-lined maw twisted
into a permanent ominous grin.
At this point, Dr. Segal realized that being
chased around constantly by a demonic, skull-faced
anomaly in real life wasn’t nearly as whimsical
as he expected it would be.
In hindsight, that probably should have been
obvious, shouldn’t it?
Though please, let us know if you’d like
MalO to stalk you in real life in the comments
below, you bunch of weirdos...
Now go check out “SCP-1471 - Mal0 Version
1.0.0” and “SCP-914 What Did YOU Put In
It!?” for more on today’s unique and strange
anomalies!